Hi. I'm David Newman.
I'm going to introduce you to
enterprise knowledge
graph capabilities.
First of all, let me,
describe this from a very high
perspective. New frontiers and
innovation require investments
in new foundational
building blocks.
For example, the mapping of
the human genome is
a representation
of a first of
a kind model that's
a prerequisite step
in innovations.
Secondly, novel technologies
must be developed
that know how
to effectively
exploit the model,
such as DNA
sequencing technologies
that developed to
exploit the mapping
of the human genome,
and their focus is
on reintegrating
fragmented parts
of DNA so that
novel innovations could emerge
that reflect
critical breakthroughs
such as, the mRNA,
vaccines for COVID,
cancer genomics,
personalized medicine.
Similarly, in finance,
we're doing the same
basic process
to innovate new capabilities.
In this case,
we're mapping the financial
genome using knowledge graph
models called ontologies,
and new technologies
have emerged
to exploit these very powerful
representational models.
Knowledge graph technologies
focus on reintegrating
the fragmented
parts of data.
Examples of technologies,
that we need to exploit for
knowledge graph are graph and
virtual graph databases,
knowledge driven
data catalogs,
and data fabrics, and
graph algorithms,
and graph neural networks,
just to name a few.
And these will result in some
new innovations,
such as advanced ways
of understanding,
customer, customer
three sixty,
ways to better, solve
financial crimes,
make risk more
visible to better
manage it, improvements in
regulatory compliance,
and significant
improvements in
data management.
Knowledge graph
is really the way
forward for data.
So let's look at this chart.
At the bottom are things that
humans can understand,
and at the top are things that
machines can understand.
In parallel is
the expressivity
of the information model.
The more expressive
the information
model, the more powerful will
its linkage and insights be.
So let's look at this
chronologically.
So around nineteen seventy,
the relational model,
the prevailing model
today emerged,
which focuses on looking at,
columns and tables,
which describes,
basically,
information in terms
of strings or numbers that are
represented as
attributes within
entities, relational databases
emerged in around
nineteen eighty five.
Fast forward to
the twenty first
century with the emergence of
knowledge graph models
and databases,
we could look at this area as
a subset of
artificial intelligence
known as
knowledge representation
and reasoning or ontologies,
which looks at data as things
and not as strings.
So looking at this, graph,
data is look is looked at as
first class objects
or nodes in
the graph that are associated
with other nodes
in a graph that
reflect relationships.
That's what these
lines or edges are,
and more about that later.
So around two
thousand and twelve,
knowledge graph models and
databases were
able to converge
with machine learning where we
can leverage new analytic
capabilities in
this area called
knowledge graph completion,
where the algorithms converge
with the knowledge
graph database
can infer new relationships,
new linkages,
link prediction,
classification, categorization
in order to create
new nodes and
create linkages between these
nodes to reflect
new insights.
And then we can further evolve
forward around
two thousand and
sixteen with the emergence of
graph neural networks,
which represent
the intersection
of knowledge
representation and
reasoning with
machine learning,
deep learning, and natural
language processing
to generate
what we would call knowledge
graph embeddings or
vectorized things,
which are ways of
representing,
very concrete pieces
of information
alternatively in,
numeric representation
or vector
representation so
that it aligns
much better with
machine learning
algorithms in order to apply,
new techniques,
new analytic
techniques that can,
understand and
express data that
would otherwise be represented
in a more
conventional database
in order to gain new insights
in very precise
ways of clustering
information. And
this ultimately is,
right now,
a way for machines
to understand
information that humans could
also understand.
So knowledge graph
really is a strategic
capability that transcends
relational data capabilities.
So when we look
at the prevailing
relational data paradigm,
one of the things that really
stands out is
what I would call
it duality or dualistic,
scenarios where the model is
segregated from
the physical model,
which is segregated
from the metadata,
from the data.
These are all separate.
These are all,
nonintegratable.
So this also results in,
tremendous incongruency and
fragmentation,
which results in
a lot of data
management problems,
a lot of, complexity,
a lot of limitations in what
the prevailing relational
paradigm can,
actually achieve in terms of
what we really need
to, to support the,
you know, very complex
data needs today.
So the emergence
of the knowledge
graph paradigm
positions us much
better for the future
because data,
because the data
the model around
that data plus metadata plus
knowledge are all linked and
integrated together.
So I call this nondualistic.
They're not segregated.
They're integrated
in a way that
allows us to connect data to
knowledge about that data.
It's connected
through this new
paradigm rather
than segregated
in a relational paradigm.
So the ability
to actually link
knowledge to raw data,
and I'll explain that a little
further on, is a is
a huge achievement.
So linking the data
to its model,
to its metadata,
and knowledge about that data
is gonna stimulate
some very new
innovations and tremendous
business value.
Well, let's dive
into first what
a graph is so we could better
understand what
a knowledge graph is.
So a graph is a unique form of
data organization
that describes
networks of connected data.
So we can look at this,
example here of
a network or a graph,
which is reflected with nodes
connected to other
nodes by these lines,
which we call edges.
These are connectors.
For example, we could say that
person a is a node,
person b, c,
and d are examples of nodes.
And we can label
the edges, with the,
predicate pays,
and we could then
get a visualization
at a at a data structure that
indicates that person a pays
both person b and c,
and b and c both
pay person d.
And this is a very
powerful data
structure that can
be used to reflect,
use cases such as,
anti money laundering,
payments networks,
ways of better
detecting fraud,
technology asset
management, where,
again, the basic organization
of the data for the use cases
and network.
So so the idea here is to use
a data organization
that better
reflects the use case than
alternatively
slicing and dicing
this into tabular views that
don't reflect this
holistic picture.
So what is a knowledge graph?
So a knowledge graph is a very
highly expressive form of data
organized in a graph,
except that
the knowledge graph
allows us to describe concepts
that describe
the data itself.
And this representation of
concepts in a logical model is
also known as an ontology.
It's a way of representing
knowledge and
describing meaning.
A very standardized form of
representing ontologies in is
a language called RDFOWL,
and it's the global semantic
modeling standard.
It's the a modeling standard
that's best used to represent
knowledge graphs because it's
of its expressivity,
and it's
linguistically aligned
with how we think and speak.
And, basically,
what this will do is allow us
to take unstructured content
definitions and translate it
into a structured
form that not
only humans can understand,
but machines can understand.
So as an example,
we could describe
a model where
we have a customer,
associated with
a checking account
and a credit card account,
and we have this
notion of this
edge that we could label with
the meaning has
account so that
this is very intuitively
understandable to a human.
We can describe concepts and
other concepts and
the and the linkage
of these is what we would call
a predicate. And
these could be
further defined in a very rich
taxonomy where we
could describe
that checking and credit card
accounts are kinds
of accounts,
and that checking and credit
card accounts also have common
behaviors or attributes.
In this case, they both share
common behavior that they will
have transactions
that associate
to another first class object
called the transaction,
which will also have a fan out
of relationships that describe
the meaning of
the transaction,
that it's meaningful
in that a transaction
may reflect the purchase from
a merchant, and it may reflect
the purchase amount,
which is some monetary value.
And that this
could be all again
represented using
a standardized
common semantic language like
RDFOWL that is also
highly reusable,
which we'll describe
a little more,
in a moment, and
it's something
that humans and machines can
both understand.
So a knowledge graph elevated
to an enterprise level
is an enterprise
knowledge graph,
and this is where
the knowledge
graph model,
is standardized and is highly
reusable across
the enterprise,
and it organically
grows bottom
up from use cases where new
business elements and,
business behaviors
are represented
in this model that
has enterprise
reuse reusability capability.
And this also,
positions us for,
leveraging a common semantic
language across the enterprise
for better,
data integration
as well as for
improved
interoperability because
this knowledge graph model
leverages open web protocols.
So essentially, we're
superimposing the,
power and behavior
of the Internet
across our data
and the ability
to link data and
information in
the Internet is
very similar to
how we link and integrate data
across an enterprise
knowledge graph.
So let's take the model we
described a little
bit earlier,
and we can now introduce data
to that model where
we can execute
new transactions
for in this case,
a customer has
a consumer credit
card account where
there are one
to many transactions that all
fan out to
the same standardized
description of
data that reflects
transactions, monetary values
associated with merchants,
and this fan out
can further occur.
Now with the semantic web,
what we're doing is we're
prelinking
information together
using the fan out of the,
web of data that
all aligns with
a common conceptual model,
and we can ask
certain questions.
So we may ask a,
some information
about a merchant,
and we may ask for
a given merchant,
who are the customers across
the enterprise that interface
with this merchant even though
some of the customers are
domiciled in
different lines of
businesses. So for example,
consumer credit card line of
business may have different,
databases than the consumer
debit card line of business or
the commercial card line of
business or
the business credit
card line of business.
But if these databases are
represented semantically as
graph databases,
then we will be
able to, engineer,
federation
and interoperability
across these databases because
we all aligned to
the same common
model and the same web enabled
protocols where
we could simply
ask a question of a merchant,
and that question
will traverse these,
web enabled interfaces and
linkages over the web of data
in order to basically,
identify that the ultimate
customers associated with this
merchant can be
identified even
though they may be,
stored in different databases
across the enterprise.
So we could better enable
enterprise linkage
using the semantic
web, and the web protocol for
advanced interoperability.
So, one more,
point I wanna
make here is that
knowledge graph can apply
knowledge to data in order to
infer new insights
and relationships.
For example, the concept of
corporate control, Again,
it's broken down
into this notion
of subject,
predicate, object,
which again is linguistically
aligned with how we
think and speak.
So let's take this example.
A corporation is an example of
a subject, controls
another corporation,
predicate, and another object
represents this concept of
corporate control.
And then we can weave more
specificity into this concept
by saying that
controls majority
voting shares is
a kind of controls.
We can add more
specificity to subjects,
predicates, and objects.
And then we can introduce data
and link it to the model where
we could say that
Global Bank,
a data assertion,
is a type of a corporation,
and New York Bank is a type of
corporation. Now
once we've done
this and this is
actually a significant
leap because within
knowledge graph,
data and the metadata
around it
and the conceptual
model around
that can all be interlinked
within the web.
So it's all operationalized.
We can then say
that Global Bank,
a type of corporation,
controls the majority voting
shares of New York Bank.
And then we can also introduce
additional concepts that is
majority controlled by,
is the inverse of controls
majority voting shares.
They're the polar opposites of
each other, and we
could introduce
this into our model.
And now you can see we're
introducing some
knowledge into
the model by virtue of how we
introduce concepts.
And then we may be able to say
that New York Bank,
because it,
is, has its major
is controlled
by Global Bank.
Global Bank controls
the majority
voting shares of
New York Bank.
Therefore, New York Bank is
majority controlled
by Global Bank.
We could draw that inference.
And then we could further draw
the inference that
once we model
that a parent company,
and a subsidiary company have
a relationship such
that the subsidiary
company is majority controlled
by the parent
company given that
New York Bank must
play the role
of the subsidiary company,
and Global Bank
must play the role
of the parent company.
And these are very powerful
inferences that we could make
by linking the data
to the concepts,
establishing and defining
knowledge about
those concepts.
And the knowledge
really emerges
when we draw these inferences
to basically infer that Global
Bank must be a parent company
and New York Bank must be
subsidiary company
of Global Bank.
And having this data linked to
concept and
knowledge is really
a very powerful enabler and
bridge to more
advanced machine
learning and the introduction
of more precise, insights.
So with that, I'm gonna turn
the presentation over
to my colleague,
Omar Khan, to
continue with his,
part of the presentation.
Thank you very much.
Hi. Thanks for
joining David and
me today to talk
about the enterprise
knowledge graph.
I'd like to talk a little bit
about the current
unlinked data
environment and
how adding linked
data approaches will help with
better integration
with an easier
infrastructure consolidation.
So when you have a linked data
environment, what that allows
you to do is have
various views
so that you can have the view
of the data if it's
materialized,
or you can have
it run ad hoc.
For example, if you
see the banking
data here,
it's named with
various different
names and different silos for
for Acme Widgets.
However, when we
go to take a look
at the data in
a federated view,
what we see is we
can pull these
names together and work with
them with ease without having
to go across
different systems.
This provides you
with a common
query facade that
you could use
with RESTful APIs,
SQL, SPARQL,
or GraphQL. This could be used
to feed a dedicated EKG.
Moving on to the next slide.
If you have an,
enterprise knowledge graph,
you could do
something even more
powerful. You could tie in
question answering mechanisms
where it uses natural language
where you built a model that
humans can use to
perform inquiries.
One thing I believe will be
emerging is where instead of
creating specific restful
interfaces or other
sorts of APIs,
you will in fact
be using a bot
using natural
language that will
talk to the knowledge
graph and
get information
out of it based
off of question and
answering models.
Of course, there'll
be security
issues in which such coarse
grained facilities exist.
The other major
benefit of having
an enterprise knowledge graph
is you could find
out what sort
of concepts are similar.
For example, we
had Acme Widgets
Corporation, Acme Widgets,
Acme Widgets Incorporated,
and Acme Widgets
Incorporated.
They're spelled
different ways,
but the reality is they're
equivalent to the same thing.
In the previous slide,
you saw we we had linked data
that gave you the ability to
perform federation
amongst the data
that exist. However,
it didn't provide a model that
gave similarity.
It's true you could get a lot
of value by by mapping
and conventions.
That said,
what we could do
is apply vector
based models on
top of the data,
which would give us
enhanced similarity.
A lot of the recipe is taking
relationships and text,
creating chains of concepts
within that the graph,
and then seeing
what is similar,
making the matrix values that
could be run with mathematical
algorithms. So using graph
embeddings and neural network
based models would give you
additional lift from
the transformation.
You want to be sure, though,
to train the model correctly.
My shirt says
a clockwork onion.
It should say
a clockwork orange,
but it says
a clockwork onion.
So the the the computer split
this out wrong with a bad
similarity model,
or the human input
the data incorrectly?
It doesn't matter.
You need to look
at the data in
the knowledge graph
and the models,
and that's example
possible results.
You could also
perform all sorts
of visualizations
with your your
with your knowledge graph.
However, you probably don't
wanna overwhelm
the person who's
looking at the graph with too
much information.
Instead, really
focus on providing
a user interface as meaningful
to them and can
be exploratory.
There's a lot of tooling that
provides data exploration and
the ability to
navigate the graph.
However, typical end users are
too busy to go
through this sort
of paradigm. Make the user
interface clean and simple,
and provide
a selected slice of
the graph that'll be
meaningful to them.
Also in the user interface,
keep references
to the knowledge
graph to provide
additional value.
Thanks for your time,
and I hope you enjoyed
our presentation.
If you're interested
in best practices,
please check out
the Enterprise
Knowledge Graph Foundation at
e k g f dot org.